jacques gaye henri emmanuelli
il
bonsoir bonsoir de vous recevoir henry
alors vous êtes député ps président du
conseil général des landes partisans du
non pardon parce qu'ils ont dû ménard
n'a pas donc je crois qu'on apprenne de
cravate
on va changer la crainte des retombées
annuelles depuis votre cravate ans et on
va la changer
ignoble on me dit elle est ignoble
est-ce qu'il peut changer de travail va
pas c'est trop tard le rhône et la
cuisson moi je moi je la trouve pas mal
et il insiste
on continue de bien
alors donc on va parler du référendum
évidemment au sujet de l'europe le 29
mai alors il ya eu un vote au ps pour
savoir s'il fallait voter oui ou non et
le résultat bat c oui à 59% donc en
bonne logique
excusez moi de vous dire aussi crûment
henry et vous devriez la ferme est en
bonne logique
oui mais là j'étais cela j'ai un petit
problème j'arrête c'est que moi je
considère que certains ou de choses se
sont passées depuis et qui font que je
ne peux pas garder le silo donc vous
refusez les consignes de silence imposée
par françois hollande
vous ne respectez pas là la discipline
du parti
mais pourtant quand même 59% c'est un
vote démocratique régir appartement où
il ya 59 %
c'est quand vous devez respecter la
démocratie c c est ce qui je pense
aujourd'hui c'est pas seulement les
militants socialistes ya des millions
d'électeurs socialistes et moi je pense
que le 29 mai on s'apercevra que dans
leur immense majorité les électeurs
socialistes eux auront voté non
effectivement une lettre ouverte aux
adhérents du ps annonçant le lancement
de la campagne pour un non socialiste
pour vous le oui c'est une erreur
historique car il ne prend pas en compte
la dimension sociale de l'europe sur ce
que vous dites en gros c'est que si on
vote oui on va aligner l'europe sur le
libéralisme anglo-saxon en gros et qu'on
va perdre cette notion de de filet
social qui fait la particularité de
l'europe oui avait avec sur tout sujet
qui me paraît très grave et qui va
devenir le sujet dominant dans l'est
les années qui viennent qui est celui de
l'emploi et du salariat en europe c'est
à dire m la question des délocalisations
je pense car ne se préoccupant pas de ce
sujet la social démocratie européenne
comme est une erreur historique parce
que des millions de femmes et d'hommes
vont se retrouver dans la précarité et
au chômage ou bien avec des salaires en
baisse et que çà cette eau ouvrir une
voie royale à l'extrême droite sur ce
vieux continent qui malheureusement à
malte et ses dents pour vous votez oui
c'est accepter la dérive libérale de
l'europe cesser d'accepter la dérive
libérale pour moi voter non c'est pas
voté contre l'europe je suis européen
je fais partie de ceux qui ont converti
le parti socialiste au fédéralisme
européen
mais je pense qu'on peut être pour
l'europe et contre ce traité un petit
peu comme la france on a pu être contre
la constitution 58 sans être contre la
république
alors on va essayer de nous faire croire
le contraire on va nous dire si vous
êtes contre le traité c'est que vous
êtes contre l'europe non voilà donc le
11 mars sur france bleu gascogne vous
avez quand même sorti votre faute phrase
lâchée le has a fait le tour du pays
assez rapidement vous avez dit la
majorité du parti n'est pas infaillible
certes 26 59% pour le oui c'est pas pour
ça qu'ils ont raison et alors vous avez
effectivement donné deux preuves de ce
que vous de ce que vous annonciez vous
avez dit en 1940
la majorité des socialistes à voter les
pleins pouvoirs vous avez dit laval en
fait c'est péta bon lait pendant la
guerre d'algérie la majorité socialiste
était d'accord pour envoyer le le
contingent en algérie pour garder
l'algérie française voilà j'ai donné
deux exemples pour montrer que même
quand on est majoritaire n'a pas
forcément raison et à partir de là on a
construit un procès d'intention par
analogie à nadi puisqu'il est dit ça ça
veut dire qu'il traite ceux qui vont
voter pour le oui
n'est ce pas de pétainiste alors ça fait
quand même beaucoup s'appelle une
association d'idées ça s'appelle un
raisonnement par analogie 1 c'est pas
très correct oui car il ne m'a pas
traversé l'esprit que ceux qui vont
voter oui
n'est ce pas aurait donné les pleins
pouvoirs au maréchal fait n'accepte pas
traversé l'esprit mais quand même c'est
vrai quand on dit ceux qui ont résisté
sans passer à la postérité ceux qui ont
pas résisté
l'époque on était couvert d'opprobe
c'est dire qu'aujourd'hui excusez moi
mais bon les choses je veux dire ce
qu'elle veut le dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui malgré tout voté oui
c'est un peu être comme ces députés
socialistes qui votent les pleins
pouvoirs à pétain ou guy mollet qui
envoie le bon d'argent en algérie l'âge
il s'agit pas de la bière quand même là
il s'agit de voter pour un traité oui
moi je veux bien qu'après on ait tiré
n'est ce pas les choix ont leur faire
dire ce qu'elles veulent pas dire mais
vous saviez bien en disant ça quand même
c'était un petit peu que j'ai fait comme
si les gens du oui était un peu des
collabos quand même
henry henry est pourquoi pas mais c'est
la polémique et c'est pourquoi pas déjà
c'est parce que tu es sud ouest c'est la
polémique
l'éloquence et la polémique - agen je ne
polémique avec les socialistes moi je
fais campagne non pas dans le parti mais
dans le pays
ouais et je dis aux socialistes nous
votez pas pour ceux traités pour un
certain nombre de réseaux un françois
hollande le patron du ps a parlé de
dérapage inadmissible
il a dit que faisait appel aux peurs aux
frilosités au monde songe aux amalgames
et par l'intelligence aux robes écouter
en matière d'intelligence comme je ne
suis pas un spécialiste je laisse les
autres
seul un énoncé n'est ce pas il a il a
dit c'est pas en disant non que l'europe
va devenir socialiste c'est à dire que
il vous donne pas l'impression un peu de
baisser les bras finalement d'être un
peu finalement bon il part comme une
fatalité la dérive libérale de l'europe
une certaine pas je vous dirais que je
ne sais pas si en disant non l'europe à
devenir socialiste mais je suis sûr
qu'en disant oui elle n'a aucune chance
de l'être
pas mal alors le problème c'est votre
copain mélenchon là jean luc mélenchon à
votre copain du nouveau monde là votre
courant le nouveau monde
alors oui vous êtes totalement
désapprouvé je comprends pas parce que
lui il est pour le nom aussi mélenchon
il vous a complètement laissé tomber il
a dit on va mettre le nouveau monde
notre mouvement commun en sommeil
jusqu'au 29 mai qu'est ce qui s'est
passé est pas bien ce jeu là pro
monsieur pas bien du tout les choix et
la non il n'est pas sur cette ligne est
fort c'est que même à l'intérieur du nom
à l'interdît non agrément corps des sous
groupes ya des urgences m'embrouiller
débrouillez pour le nord ont bien fermé
l'enfant et non mais mais c'est pas
comme vous il vous a totalement
désapprouvé il veut plus faire le
nouveau monde où henry je pense qu'il ya
pas beaucoup de françaises ou tracé qui
se couchent le soir à 10 ans comme
problème majeur de savoir ce que à bien
a dit sur émail ou manu pourquoi les
mecs du nom commence à faire mal qu'on
se pose des questions quant à la bourre
on vous demande de voter non ya pas un
risque de schisme de scission cette
histoire il ya un vrai problème
d'orientation politique 1 entre ce que
moi j'ai appelé les sociaux libéraux qui
ont fait des gens qui acceptent cette
logique du capitalisme financier ou
réactionnaire n'est ce pas en caisse et
où le salarié trinquent
1 on est quand même dans une europe où
le dividende augmente deux fois plus
vite que les salaires
et ça fait gros problème en ce moment
dans notre pays comme vous le savez ils
sont pas longtemps et pas content parce
que le pouvoir d'achat a reculé
oui mais comme on sait que quand
raffarin dit quelque chose en général
c'est pas suivies d'effets et c'est pour
ça à mon avis le ton attitude c'est pas
positive attitude
si c'est pour dire du mal de mélenchon
il paraît que syfy joli tir je retire et
le champ parce que je vais encore en
sellerie mais mélenchon il paraît que si
fait des meetings avec les communistes
il sera viré du ps voilà tout ce qu'a
dit alors est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
peur d'être viré henry ça ne pas sérieux
henry si vous virez moi j'ai peur d'être
viré par l'histoire mais pas rien d'où
le nom je ne m'en fous pas parce que je
pense que dire qu'on s'en fout ce serait
être prises en penser que l'opinion des
mois je respecte tout le monde
simplement je pense que c'est ma
responsabilité elle n'est peut-être pas
énorme mais elle existe vous avez le
sentiment d'être comme de gaulle quand
il est parti à londres en 40
lui je n'irai pas jusque là mais je
pense en revanche que être socialiste
c'est d'abord être résistant rebelles
ce n'est pas s'accommoder de l'ordre
existant alors l'ordre établi surtout ne
vous a rien rapporté cette affaire parce
que donc tout le monde nous est tombé
dessus et mêmes les magazines comme le
point le nouvel observateur vous met en
baisse à cause de votre phrase là là je
sens que ça va
handicapé magnima prochaines nuits alors
bien y avoir d'enquêté libyenne l'ump
alors l'ump il ya une porte parole qui
s'appelle valérie pécresse alors elle a
dit emmanuelli marche sur les
plates-bandes de monsieur le pen bon on
a bon et d'une mais après là où ça
devient quand même beaucoup plus grave
pour vous elle parle de propos
inqualifiables
elle parle de réécriture de l'histoire
et elle dit que la réécriture de
l'histoire a toujours été larmes des
extrémistes alors vous avez pas réécrit
l'histoire je gagne c'est bien quand
même une majorité de députés socialistes
a bien voté les pleins pouvoirs à pétain
c'est vrai ça la majorité de la sfio à
l'époque à voter ces fioles guy mollet a
bien envoyé le montage en algérie a
réécrit l'histoire et madame pécresse me
paraît d'une inculture historique assez
grande
j'ai d'ailleurs fait passer un mot au
président de l'assemblée à de braire
l'écouté si elle pense que le pen
n'était pas pour vichy et n'était pas de
jerry française il faudra changer de
porte-parole 1 j'ai d'ailleurs reçu un
mail assez intéressant le professeur de
médecine qu'il leur a adressée en disant
je vote pour de gaulle depuis pour les
gaullistes depuis 20 ans 1
mais si vous ne changez pas cette dame
qui manifestement ne comprend rien hein
quoi que la prochaine fois c'est à dire
que c'est vrai qu'elle vous compare un
peu elle dit vous faites la réécriture
de l'histoire c'est grave en france
quand on parle de réécriture de
l'histoire on pense aux négationnistes
on pense à fort hills y ont veillé que
c'est quand même un qui est grave c'est
de voter oui à ce traité et pourquoi
parce que ce traité je déconne à une
mais pour une fois qu'il était sérieux
mais que son truc tombe bien à propos
ouais ouais mais j'arrive je pose la
question mais je n'arrive pas à
m'intéresser à la réponse mais c'est
personnel
ça veut dire quoi l'euro ça veut dire
que les enjeux de ces votes échéant
deuxième sujet vous parler j'ai ouï
n'intéresse non ça veut dire que je ne
le comprends pas c'est on en reparlera
tout à l'heure c'est vrai que c'est
chaud en ce moment au ps lui mars à
guéret dans la creuse
françois hollande a été victime d'une
bataille de boules de neige
c'est à dire qu'ils avaient une
manifestation ils veulent manifester
soutien aux services publics et françois
hollande a été victime de deux jeux de
boules de neige et lui les batailles de
mélenchon et fabius a dit de faits
l'homme cheveux il fabius a dit on le
sentait venir sûr que quand même non
mais c'est grave quand même bon il
s'échauffe attaqué le le premier
secrétaire a la boule de neige sur la
voie d'une fiabilité fabius était obligé
de faire
fabius est obligé de faire son auto
critique ou au bureau national
alors c'est quand même moi je n'apprécie
pas qu'on ait jeté des boules de neige
vous étiez quoi sur françois hollande
qui est un homme que j'ai estimé que je
respecte il est pas mal ce que ce qu'ils
ont fait ça tron tutor voilà bon tuteur
oui bon on this or et j'ai dit ça sans
tuteur il ya il ya un truc il ya un truc
est ce qu'on vous on comprend encore bon
vous êtes pour le non et tout parce que
vous êtes quand même très à gauche du
parti socialiste mais un titre comme
fabius qui lui quand même terrible ça
fait combien d'années que vous le
supportez ça fait depuis 92 ça fait
d'années on a changé la caravane je
savais qu'il était admirable merad qui
s'habille en noir s'imposent
l'avez-vous en comprend pas ce que bon
vous êtes quand même toujours très à
gauche du ps je suis pas fier et très à
gauche mais fabius par exemple lui c'est
vrai que c'est plus bizarre quand même
un type qui a toujours était quand même
très social libéral pourquoi il est pour
le nom penser que c'est pour se
positionner pour la présidentielle de
je sentais venir l'empoisonnement de la
présidentielle dans ce pays depuis cinq
ans le plus parler de rien sans corps
aussitôt ça tourne à la présidentielle
avant quand j'étais petit c'était le
lait qui tournait maintenant c'est une
décision politique qui tourne à la
présidentielle en permanence l'aï vendue
comme moi je ne souhaite pas qu'on
pollue ce débat important pour les
français pour l'europe parce que ça va
nous engager pour 30 ou 50 ans n'est ce
pas avec le choix du candidat
on fera le choix du candidat l'année
prochaine et je n'ai qu'une certitude
c'est que des candidats il y en aura
trop n'y aura pas besoin de faire
d'appel c'est le pas candidat vous ont
coûté en 95
vous avez été candidat à la candidature
peut-être qu'après cette émission xi lan
audimat suffisant on dit raymond chirez
mai mais pour l'instant je m'occupe de
l'europe
vous êtes libre en fête par rapport à la
plaque en six axes
m
elle vous plaît cette chance quand même
beaucoup j'ai pensé c'est un peu votre
hymne en ce moment un pensé j'y ai pensé
il est libre max les portes du
pénitencier
mais ce que j'aimerais c'est pouvoir
expliquer mais on se reverra j'en suis
sûr mardi pourquoi pourquoi ils ont
beaucoup envoient leurs droits cette
europe n'est pas démocratique
je voudrais pouvoir expliquer aussi
pourquoi elle et pas sociale et ce sont
ces raisons de fond qui me pousse à dire
voter non ne rejetez pas l'europe mais
n'acceptez pas l'europe qu'on veut vous
vendre à toute force en mélangeant votre
attachement à l'europe avec une
politique de droite c'est vrai que cette
semaine j'ai lu barroso là le patron de
l'europe la télé là il agressif pépère
il y à gré s'il fait plus alors ils
pensent savoir il a dit chirac jeune à
la voie le chauffeur pareil j'ai lettre
à monsieur chirac pour lui d'écouter je
comprends pas chaque fois que vous dit
quelque chose monsieur vient commissaire
européen qui dit le contraire
j'ai fait une lettre pour lui demander
quand même s'ils pensaient pas que la
france était sérieusement de kitimat
alors attendez en 92 étiez pour
maastricht absolument y avait des gens
avec enthousiasme y avait des gens qui
en 92 disait attention si on fait
l'europe gens votent oui à maastricht
on va se retrouver avec des barroso qui
vont nous dire ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui on y est
donc vous vous êtes trompés en 80 ans et
sa non se perd les eaux calmes et
mitterrand pas trop la ramener
j'ai pas sentiment à l'époque s'agissait
de faire l'euro - regrette pas que
l'euro existe même si les mâles j'irai
si c'est difficile il est très mal gérée
monsieur trichet aujourd'hui fait une
politique qui nous coûte à peu près 7
points de croissance depuis 2000 et donc
des millions de chômeurs pourquoi parce
qu'on a une route trop élevé par rapport
au dollar qui est à vous
problème c'est qu'il a le droit de vote
derrière j'avais plein de gens allaient
maintenant il ya plein de gens à
l'époque qui disaient il va y avoir des
barroso qui vont nous dire ce qu'il faut
faire et aujourd'hui vous dites c'est là
dans l'arrondi sais que je risque de
villiers disant 83 ans n'aurait jamais
pu faire
mais si le virus et les européens qui
vont diriger la france
vous dites je disais à l'époque je ne
dis pas ça et vous le savez très bien et
n'hésitez pas vous ne le ferez pas dire
c'est lourdingue mais oui c'est vrai
quoi enfin moment bon moi je suis
convaincu je vais voter non
oui nous sommes pour que j'arrête
non pas qu'on reconnaît tant qu'on ne
fait pas n'importe quelle sera la portée
voilà alors sérieusement est-ce que
l'europe n'ait pas déjà dépassé
finalement n'est ce pas un joueur n'est
pas une pierre face à la mondialisation
à ce que l'europe n'ait pas déjà dépassé
non je disais tout à l'heure par face
aux délocalisations 1
je pense que l'europe va devoir se
protéger avoir un tarif extérieur commun
elle en avait au départ elle abandonné
ensuite les états unis le fond je vois
pas pourquoi l'europe ne pourrait pas le
faire alors ça veut pas dire qu'il
faille faire du protectionnisme mais ça
veut dire qu'il faut avoir un colt dans
la botte pour pouvoir éventuellement se
défendre il y a des choses à faire dans
le sens du progressisme et dans le sens
d'une europe
umanis est ce qu'on veut nous fabriquer
c'est une europe anglo saxon est
conservatrice et moi je suis socialiste
alors me dit mais il faut quitter le
parti où il faut plus laide mais je peux
pas
thierry chez 3 milliards de cellules
comme tout comme vous avez 3 milliards
avec un noyau dans chaque cellule elles
sont tous socialistes